for every 100 000 youtube channels yeah
there is one that will get a breakout
that does well and blows up yeah out of
those channels that blow up there is
maybe one in ten that understands what
they need to do to change their content
and to keep evolving to have an
everlasting like presence on the
platform yeah you know people like uh
you know michael reeves had like a few
videos that blew up yeah he understood
what he needed to do i don't know i i
don't know maybe he did i don't know if
he did it could have been sheer dumb
luck you know but he was making moves
and he was making the content and
upgrading the things in the places that
needed to be upgraded you know i thought
maybe michael reeves doesn't feel like
he'd blow up but i i when i watched
michael reeves he didn't the whole
[ __ ] when his whole branding was the
laser pointer in the eye guys yeah yeah
yeah yeah um that was how he started and
uh he just blew up from there and he
kept riding the wave and he kept doing
what was right you know because a lot of
people and more often than not the
channels that do die are ones that had
massive explosions and growth yeah
that's what scares me actually because
if you have massive growth
something is going you've kind of hit
the nail on the head in so many ways and
you probably don't understand why yeah
because you this is just sheer luck to
you and the first instincts is to go
keep doing the same say that again yeah
because you know when you when you first
do it and you have uh steady growth yeah
i think all of us have had pretty steady
growth i'd say none of us have had
months so we've blown up insane amounts
yeah um you you get you afford the
cushion to make the mistakes
of uploading repetitive content
realizing that's not the way to do it
you get to slowly make all these
mistakes yeah
and it gives you kind of like a a very
nice cushion of i can make these
mistakes and then i can learn from them
it's it's like the buffer that you get
yeah because to me the the biggest thing
that scares me when i see
like maybe an up-and-coming youtuber or
maybe like a new youtube make making
content on the platform is when they
have one or two videos that blow up it's
it and then it's it's a pattern i see
where you have one or two videos that
get millions and millions of views and
then the next video gets like 20k videos
yeah like i've seen that so many times
like like mr beast right mr beast uh
blew up on some weird [ __ ] videos
like yeah yeah counting counting to 100
000 yeah like insane 10 000 iq yeah and
then he just kept building on it he
never he never ever
repeated something for too long yeah you
know he he repeated it a little bit
which is fine you can do that i'm not
saying don't repeat ideas he deviated
like oh yeah you made it like a
derivation you know so then he would he
would do something like watching logan
paul every day bro for 10 hours yeah
right or 24 hours right so he took what
was successful about the one video yeah
sorry jake paul wow
fake youtuber terrible
he took that he took the aspect that
people liked which is watching something
for an absurd amount of time or doing
something and then applying it to
something else and it worked and then he
realized okay now i'm getting all the
success how do i then what's what's kind
of the virality here what's what's
enticing people it's just the end
an insane absurd nature of what he's
doing so then he decided i'm gonna spend
a [ __ ] ton of money which is like the
next best step if you can waste a ton of
time what goes hand in hand with wasting
time spending too much money yeah two
sides of the same coin like it's the
same thing yeah and it's genius yeah he
he was just the master of making content
that was so ridiculous that no one could
emulate it yeah no no one wanted no one
wanted to emulate i mean i mean what
watching mr beast right it's just it's
just like a master class in youtube i'm
just like i'm watching mr beast and like
every time he makes something new or
makes new moves or something it's like
you know you know when like you feel
like you you feel like that side
character in an anime that's just like
okay this is the genius character and
i'm just merely the side character in
his story that's what i feel like
watching the beast side character that
has to commentate every movie
i can't believe he just did that move
what's that i'll explain it like when
when he just like [ __ ] opened a
burger chain i was just like you are
[ __ ] mad but that is like the most
genius movie yeah i could ever see
anyone doing because no one no one's
even close to his genius and like i
don't know like i i think part of it is
just experience because like mr beast
went so many years making so many
different types of content and then he
blew up like i think like seven years
into his youtube career so he just has a
lot of experience under his belt but
there is just a natural genius to some
of the stuff that he does that it's just
unmatched by every other content creator
right now yeah and and you know god
forbid there are so many channels out
there right now that are trying to do
something of similar taste to what mr
beast is i mean i think he's in varying
levels i think we'd be lying if like we
hadn't taken some kind of idea or a
concept oh of course from mr b onto our
own channel right
spending money are cool things yeah
exactly right that's why i'm many of my
titles there's money in it because yeah
it works yeah yeah yeah exactly i think
every youtuber has done at least one
video where they've tried to do
something similar to varying levels of
success i mean i mean you see you often
you see kind of you see content creators
like you see these type of content
creators come in the platform every so
often where they just like they're so
ahead of the game that they just like
completely revolutionize the content on
the platform like casey neistat i
remember when like every vlogger tried
to be casey neistat because he was just
when he first started making the vlogs
that he did which was just like taking
taking a day and instead of just making
like this handycam vlog but just
actually making it kind of like a short
film yeah and that was just like that
was revolutionary for the time and like
nobody could touch him for the longest
time because he had to be insane to do
what he was doing yeah he was like
guilty got like four hours of sleep and
he had like a family and like this [ __ ]
was insane like the the amount of [ __ ]
he was doing in a day i felt exhausted
watching and he has like a factory full
of cameras and then he went and then he
went home and edited it and i'm like i i
i would rather shoot myself yeah like
obviously this this looked insane it's
not dude just like daily vlogs it's just
in general totally not surprising you
got burnt out and quit doing yeah
you know anyone have you ever seen the
film limitless yeah yeah uh like i feel
like i feel like if there's any real
life example of someone who's discovered
that drug it was casey neistat when he
first got like when he first started
blowing up man because my god like it's
it's like it's such an example of
someone who's just like how how are you
finding this many hours in the day man
you are using a hundred percent of your
brain yeah you've discovered the
limitless drug yeah this is insane i
just i mean so much respect to the dude
but like just jesus christ yeah he
really set the bar high
i got exhausted thinking about what he
was doing yeah like it's insane we don't
we don't even do a tenth of what he
knows no
yeah my god like
i felt like these past three months have
problems possibly been the most busiest
three months of my life and it's still
like it's nothing compared to what
whatever the [ __ ] that he went through
at his people for years for years as
well i guess he's also taking a [ __ ] let
alone just like
thinking about doing what he's doing
yeah i mean like i don't have energy for
that
jesus
like okay so like how long
how long did it take you doing work on
youtube before you realized man it's uh
it's it's [ __ ] tiring doing videos
like
because i feel like i feel like every
youtuber goes to the phase where
like youtube making videos at some point
was just easy it was just like i'm
getting i'm getting paid something that
it's my hobby it's where you first make
a video and you're like i don't i think
i like this
i think i like this video
i think i hate this it's when you start
to become like really perfectionist
about your videos i feel because like
when you're starting off you again you
have that honeymoon period of like
everything you make is like oh that's
cool that's fun let's do that yeah i
enjoyed that yeah let's go but then as
you start to make more content and as
you start to grow and start to realize
oh i got to like up my quality and the
content and up my quality of the cameras
or whatever that's when you start to get
a little more self-reflective on your
own content right and you start to think
oh
that video i made last week that i was
loving now that i look at it could have
done a lot better on that maybe maybe
this next video i'll do a lot better
yeah and i feel that's the point where
you start to be like oh okay now this is
like seriousness
this is like a job now yeah it's like
kind of not only is my rent and like my
living on the line for this for the
success of this video but also like just
my artistic integrity of making content
now yeah is kind of on the line and i i
i don't know
well yeah i mean you know not every
youtuber can say that same thing
i feel like i don't i feel like i i just
make stuff i like i don't know right but
you know but at the same time you'd be
lying if you said that you didn't care
about how your video looked or how no of
course no i i love making a good video
so i feel in a lot of ways like as much
as you maybe don't want to admit that is
in a sense artistic integrity like you
want to make the best
you want to make the best [ __ ] you can
make yeah you want to make sure you're
proud of yeah you enjoy that that's
that's just been my philosophy and
that's why i've never like paid too much
attention to the algorithm and stuff
like that maybe maybe seeing what kind
of content is doing well or stuff like
that but at the end of the day i'd like
it sounds like such generic advice or
whatever but it's kind of true in a
sense where just good good content is
king at the end of the day there's some
there's some videos that will not
perform as well on the algorithm but
for the most part if you make good
content people are going to watch it and
then at every so often you get someone
like diamond
which just [ __ ] blows your mind
because you're just like okay i don't
understand that's the thing right i just
okay maybe maybe i'm wrong maybe maybe
my entire understanding of this platform
has just been warped